Adam you want to see more people whose
primary source of income is from their
creative outlet why is this important to
you well I think it's it's not just
important to me I think it's important
to everybody it's especially important
to the people who are creative because
it's so frustrating to be creative to
make something that's kind of wonderful
and precious and want to share it and
then not really have any mechanism to
share it and not be able to sustain
yourself and your family by sharing your
work now look I don't think all the time
that people create things they're
they're fabulous or they're great in
fact most of the time we know that
they're not we not only need a lot of
refinement and working before they are
terrific and really hit their mark for
their audience or their constituents but
the other thing that we do know is that
a lot of great creative work just
doesn't get out there it just doesn't
get seen and until we get to a place in
this country where it gets out there and
gets seen we're not taking advantage of
this amazing resource that we have as
Americans you know we used to call it
Yankee ingenuity or American ingenuity
and if you look at where we are in this
country right now I think that we're
really in a trough you can't look at our
country now and say things are going
great you can't look at our country and
say that things are not broken because
they are we're all struggling
everybody's struggling artists are
struggling creative people are
struggling our economy is struggling our
innovators are struggling why because so
many things have been outsourced Lee
right now you know today Obama and
Romney are having dueling sound bites
about who is the greater outsourcer
one's calling the great outsourcing CEO
and Romney's calling Obama the
outsourcer in chief but the real issue
is why are all these things being out
sourced and what can we keep at home
what we can keep at home is creativity
and innovation creativity cannot be
outsourced innovation cannot be out
sourced that's why it's so important
it's really important to all of us to
really maintain the country that we
livin
you